eldon ring
a couple weeks ago i made a quick
trailer breakdown for gamespot based on
my initial impressions of alden ring's
exciting gameplay reveal from summer
game fest
since then a lot has happened hidetaka
miyazaki has revealed a plethora of new
information through various interviews
so i'd love to break down what we know
so far about the game into further
detail
especially since all the gameplay we've
seen so far has been re-contextualized
thanks to these interviews
let's start with the solo gameplay in an
interview for famitsu magazine
translated by the angry furlong on
reddit miyazaki revealed that the game
will feature a heavy amount of
customization
and lots of ways to tackle dangerous
situations in the game
the game borrows heavily from gameplay
mechanics of from software's dark souls
series
in particular and while the game could
very well have been dark souls 4
miyazaki and team wanted the freedom of
a brand new world in ip but there are
still
plenty of things that are borrowed from
dark souls including the fact that
you're playing a nameless character who
you create and customize the appearance
of
elden bling here we come
there will also be a large variety of
weapons and spells both of which we saw
showcased in the trailer
but something unique will be the way
elden ring handles weapon arts
which were first introduced in dark
souls 3.
in dark souls 3 weapon arts were special
attacks that were tied to a specific
weapon
however in elden ring these weapons will
be separate skills you're able to
somehow
gain and collect every weapon has one
weapon art slot and you customize your
weapon by equipping a weapon art to it
according to miyazaki there will be
around 100 weapons that you'll be able
to obtain
another added element to the way you can
tackle enemy encounters
comes in the form of spirits you can now
summon while the specifics of this
mechanic are still a little fuzzy to me
we saw it showcased in the gameplay
trailer when the player character
crushes a cube
in the souls games the markers for
cooperative npc
phantoms you could summon to help you in
battles would appear on the ground
and you had to meet certain conditions
like not being hollow
in order to be allowed to summon certain
characters like soleir
i'm not certain yet how to gain spirits
but what i do know is that they're going
to be
according to miyazaki basically based on
enemies
so does that mean it's like pokemon
where you trap a weakened enemy
into a cube and now it's your ally
finally the dark souls pokemon game
we've all been waiting for
and by we i mean me kind of be like
persona 5
in a way if you think about it but there
are so many possibilities for how you
might gain these spirits that i don't
feel good about fully speculating on it
the spirits are an extremely interesting
addition though
because they're essentially another
weapon and tool at your disposal
they act like weapons armor or magic
that you equip to your character
and interestingly just like a weapon you
can even level up these individual
spirits
however similar to summoning a phantom
in dark souls you're only allowed to
summon these spirits in certain places
they widely vary from shield characters
who protect you to archers that'll aid
you in the back line
decoys and more according to miyazaki
there are even some spirits will be
pretty much
useless so i'm just imagining the
pendant from dark souls being a spirit
you summon that just falls in the grass
and does nothing
you then leveled up to 100 hoping it'll
be like magikarp
and it just sits there taunting you
another new yet familiar element will be
stealth
stealth was of course first introduced
in and a major part of from software's
last game
securo and this mechanic will be making
a return for eldon ring allowing you to
approach a dangerous situation in a
completely different way
and i have to imagine it'll make
backstabs a whole lot easier to
accomplish
and speaking of which we have
confirmation that parrying enemies will
be back
another gameplay element first
introduced in securo and making its way
over at elder ring
is jumping jumping was a critical
feature of battle and securo and it
sounds like it will work in a similar
way in elder ring
allowing you to jump over low sweeping
attacks i do wonder what that means for
dodging in iframes if jumping is a
viable means of countering your enemies
in the trailer we do see a couple
moments where it looks clear that the
player is dodging away and
i-frames are saving them later on in the
trailer the wolf-like boss shoots a
magic beam at the player and the player
dodges it by dashing through the beam
which looks like it's straight out of
bloodborne again the dodge and iframe
save the player character from injury
immediately after the wolf like boss
performs a low sweeping attack
and this time the player character
chooses to jump over it instead of
dashing through it
so i think it's clear that dodging and
iframes will work the exact
same way they did in dark souls the
question is
are there certain attacks you'll only be
able to properly dodge by jumping
it's definitely going to be interesting
to see how important jumping is from a
defensive perspective
from an offensive perspective you can
now jump for a heavy attack
there is a shot at the end of the elder
ring trailer which shows the player
jumping and striking at one of the
game's demigod bosses
admittedly on first watching the trailer
i thought this was just something
cinematic they were showing
but after reading miyazaki's interview
it's clear that this is a strike the
player can perform
miyazaki also compared the combat of
elder ring to sekiro and its
resurrection mechanic
while eldon ring will not feature
resurrection mechanic which allows
players to feel a sense of progression
and progress without ruining their
gameplay rhythm eldon ring will feature
similar elements to keep players engaged
and allow for a sense of meta
progression
something i found extremely notable from
an ign interview with hitake miyazaki
was a statement about the stamina bar
something that has been a prominent
feature of souls and derivative souls
like games
according to miyazaki the stamina bar
exists in elder ring
but we feel it has less influence on the
player overall
we wanted to make it feel less
restrictive and contribute to that level
of freedom more so than our previous
titles one of the game's major additions
will be horseback riding
and yes i realize they look like yakults
from princess mononoke
but for the time being horseback riding
is the term he's been using in
interviews
we see a number of battles take place on
horseback this includes one against what
looks to be a more normal enemy and one
against a dragon
as we see this horseback boss battle
against the dragon in the trailer i do
wonder if you're limited to only using
your horse in certain scenarios in the
game
miyazaki has stated that in multiplayer
you won't be able to travel on horseback
so here's what i think might be the case
as miyazaki has stated there's a large
open field you traverse via horse and
in your travels you'll find six larger
vertically designed dungeon areas known
as legacy dungeons
perhaps once you reach a legacy dungeon
you're no longer allowed to call your
horse
this would mean that for any boss or
enemy you find in the open field
your horse is another tool and way to
fight there will also be smaller
abandoned villages and runes and you'll
find bosses in some of these you can use
your horse to fight as well
in his fumitsu interview miyazaki stated
travel on horseback will be limited to
the open field but i think it really
feels nice
so this would make sense to me and
speaking of which in the battle against
the dragon
there's a scene where you don't just
jump once but double jump in mid
air so it's clear that the horse will
have unique skills not just for
traversing the world's terrain
but even for battle unlike previous from
software games
you'll be able to craft and customize
items in elder ring from various
materials you find in the world
miyazaki states that while there will be
more resources for you to recover your
health this time around
as you'll be fighting for longer than in
previous games presumably
in between other checkpoints hp recovery
will still be handled in a special way
comparable to previous titles when it
comes to overall difficulty of elder
ring
miyazaki compares it to dark souls 3.
like the spirits i was mentioning you
don't have to rely on pure mechanical
skill
but can use strategy to defeat your
enemies we are emphasizing a strategic
approach to combat in this game
this leads me nicely into multiplayer
we have official confirmation that there
will be cooperative gameplay and pvp
within
eldon ring when it comes to cooperative
multiplayer the game has been further
expanded to allow players to create
groups
these groups will have a special
appearance and are matched via password
and a group can be of an unlimited size
at least for the time being
all of this to me sounds like it means
from software is going to allow clans
within elden ring
it will be prioritized in matchmaking
with any group you set
so if you want to create a kirk fan club
a la iron pineapple
it sounds like you'll be able to quickly
match with your friends far more easily
than in any previous souls game
that said beyond this it's hard to say
if there will be any additional
functionality for these groups beyond
easier matchmaking
overall the co-op will function
similarly to dark souls and summon signs
with players only able to be summoned in
certain areas and then being booted out
after defeating a boss
something that some players struggled
with in securo was that unlike the souls
games there weren't too many options for
progressing in the game beyond getting
better at the game's core mechanics
with alden ring miyazaki will be keeping
the relative difficulty of the game
similar to souls but including many ways
for players who are less skilled
mechanically to progress
including this element of cooperative
play with other online players
and while co-op has existed in every
souls game including demon souls
miyazaki hopes to lower the barrier of
entry for this element of the game
in order to do this elder ring will
limit how many resources are necessary
for multiplayer
and you'll no longer need to use a
semi-rare resource like humanity in
order to summon
while there aren't too many details
about the pvp as of yet
we do have confirmation that it will
exist thanks to an interview with the
russian website egromania
translated by calibrono and sulky bat on
reddit
apparently miyazaki was noticeably
excited to talk about the pvp
and says there will be both invasions
and optional pvp
he also stated the team is working to
make pvp less irritating for both
players
hopefully that means we'll actually get
some kind of pvp arena in the vanilla
game
he also specifically mentioned trying to
add certain information so pvp wouldn't
just be an endless game of hide and seek
i have to imagine that thanks to the
sheer amount of customization for player
builds within elder ring
pvp will thrive in this game especially
if groups are matched with other groups
of similar sizes
finally while there will be a return of
covenants in the alden ring miyazaki
specifically compared it to demon souls
which uh has no covenants in this regard
he said there's no minimum requirement
for multiplayer and that while covenants
will return there are more so for role
playing and to spice things up
my personal favorite map design of any
from software game has been
dark souls the game has an interwoven
world and it's a blast discovering
every major shortcut and way to progress
from one area to another
however every game has handled traversal
in a slightly different manner
because there was no warping in dark
souls until the latter half of the game
this interwoven map design was
incredibly important to making traversal
less of a slog
and much more of a reward demon souls
and bloodborne both featured a main hub
with warping to distinct and separate
disconnected major areas
those areas were often times interwoven
within themselves but fairly distinct
meanwhile dark souls 2 and 3 allowed for
warping right off the bat
from one checkpoint to another this
meant that the overall maps weren't as
interwoven
but had distinct branches that would jut
out while miyazaki has stated that there
will
indeed be a hub area players won't be
able to access at the start of the game
but can eventually gain access to i
think elder ring will be completely
distinct in this regard
according to miyazaki the overall world
design will feel more like a classic rpg
the open field of the game serves to
expand the scale of the story
increasing immersion there is a great
unknown
and threat in this world and there's a
thrill of feeling your way through the
world intended to bring the joy of
discovery and travel
i think this is one of the joys that the
old classic rpgs had
and we wanted to aim for that in this
game there is what you would call a
world map for the open field areas
you can set a waypoint travel to
uncharted areas and enjoy revealing the
map
on the other hand as in the dark souls
series there is
no map in the big dungeon areas we want
you to enjoy figuring out the layout
through exploration
and to have that great feeling when you
finally do so it seems like there's a
large
exterior world map similar perhaps to a
classic jrpg-like final fantasy
or maybe even skyrim or breath of the
wild that you explore with your horse
here unlike any other modern from
software game you'll actually have a map
that you'll uncover as you discover new
locations
according to miyazaki besides the
extremely thought out vertical legacy
dungeons
there are many small to medium scale
dungeon areas
forts catacombs caves mining tunnels etc
we are planning to have many npcs but
currently there are no towns or villages
where they reside
there are places that were once villages
but are now abandoned and the prowling
places of dangerous enemies
so i imagine that all of these smaller
to medium scale dungeons
forts and the rest are a part of this
larger map and area you traverse on
horse
to my mind it will probably be somewhat
like my previous examples of breath of
the wild or skyrim
however once you find a legacy dungeon
the area within is a much more like a
classic dark souls dungeon
so imagine you're traversing along the
world and you stumble upon the tower of
latria
once you enter latria you no longer have
a map and you'll have to explore
just like you did in demon souls i'm not
sure how you enter these legacy dungeons
and if it will be something like a large
castle you'll stumble upon that you'll
explore
or if it's something you warp to
something i brought attention to in my
trailer breakdown video was
this scene of a hand grabbing a naked
character who i think is the player
initially i thought this was something
from the beginning of the game and how
you enter the lands between
i still think that's likely the case but
it's worth mentioning that a similar
mechanic could just be how you enter
into legacy dungeons
although i'd like to think every legacy
dungeon will be different both in style
and how you enter it
and can't wait to see how from software
will surprise us
further helping with this large scope of
the game elder ring will feature a fast
travel system
however we still don't know the exact
details of how this system will work
miyazaki has stated that you won't have
to defeat every boss in the game in
order to win
and that many of them are skippable
furthermore the order and timing of most
of the boss battles
is completely up to the player while the
dark souls games in particular
have always included elements of this
according to miyazaki this level of
freedom and order of progression will be
even more heightened in the elden ring
something relatively new to aid you in
traversing these areas is the ability to
jump
this is of course a mechanic that was
insecure but is now being introduced
into a much more standard souls-like
game
as i mentioned before the horse will be
able to jump which will aid you in
traversing the world
i imagine that means there will be many
hidden nooks for you to find in the
world and dangerous ledges you'll have
to try to jump
off of or land on to find hidden weapons
armor and more
additionally in the trailer we saw that
the horse can seem to jump straight up
certain cliffs
although notably before your horse does
this they actually jump off of a special
magical ring
so you'll probably be limited in the
specific ability to certain spots that
from software allows you to actually
launch from
in other words that rock creature with a
bell under it and building on top
you probably won't be able to just
launch up to the building unless
hitting the bell creates one of those
magical jumping rings who knows
miyazaki's hinted jumping will be a
major element to exploring legacy
dungeons and expressed that jumping as a
new dimension of freedom
perhaps especially players who played a
lot of dark souls series will find this
refreshing
while gravity was the number one op
enemy of dark souls
it seems that jumping has completely
changed the way falling and fall damage
will work
we've adjusted fall damage to make the
game less stressful considering that the
freedom allowed by jumping is an
important part of the game
we've made it so enemy attacks won't
cause you to fall unfairly and have
also adjusted the fall damage down
bandai namco's website
included this story dump and we get a
little more of a breakdown from hitataka
miyazaki
the background mythology of elder ring's
world was crafted by george r.r martin
which involves the lands between here a
race called the demigods have received
the blood of the divine queen marika
and are heroes that rule this land
having received a particularly powerful
blessing
all who receive this blessing have a
golden light in their eyes
but these people have lost this light
they are called tarnished because they
have lost this golden light from their
eyes
and are driven out of the lands between
the tarnished who is the protagonist of
the game is a descendant of the people
who were driven out of the lands between
and now when the elder ring which forms
the source of the blessing of the golden
tree has been shattered
this once lost blessing is returned to
the tarnished who reside outside the
lands between
it is a rumbling to become the king
which beckons you to the lands between
and to the elden ring in the trailer
we're told the tarnish will fight
or die in an unending curse so similar
to dark souls your character
a tarnished would seem to have an undead
curse upon them i find it likely that
part of this beckoning that calls your
character to the lands between
involves this particular shot of a hand
grabbing a character and taking them
away
your mission is to defeat the various
demigods who once heroes of the land
but grew mad with power after obtaining
a shard of the elder ring
you play as one of the many descendants
of the tarnished who lost their grace
and were exiled from the lands between
long long ago as miyazaki revealed in an
interview with ign
and that would indicate you aren't the
only tarnish who has been beckoned back
to the lands between
he states i feel like one of the main
themes of the game is how the player
the tarnished approaches or treats this
newfound grace and this return to the
land that they were once banished from
how they interpret this and the meaning
it's not just the player character of
course
it's lots of characters in the game who
are all beckoned back and will have
their own adventures and motives
we want the players to discover for
themselves what that means and how they
want to begin their adventure
while i'm sure that there will be plenty
of bosses as there are six
legacy dungeons and miyazaki has stated
that these are the domains of the major
demigod characters
that leads me to believe there will be a
total of 6 demigods
and it's my suspicion that many of these
demigods are those who we saw in the
original eldon ring trailer
i find it likely that the 2019 trailer
may have been footage from the intro
cinematic to the game
introducing the demigods of the world
the silver herod and crowned demigod
with multiple hands
is featured in the original trailer and
then prominently in the gameplay trailer
another one is the valkyrie-like
character who has a detachable arm
and who we see absolutely obliterating a
player character in the gameplay trailer
another character we see is a large
warrior with massive boar-like armor
who i can't find in the gameplay trailer
this looks to be straight from a
cutscene about the war that broke out
after the shattering
it's possible this character is either
dying from the war or
could be another one of the demigods
miyazaki has stated of these demigods
that
we wanted to depict these beings as not
just creatures and horrible monsters but
have an element of heroism
and an element of mythology to them
essentially they are the old gods of
this world
as the demigods were all heroes of their
time i find it strongly possible that
this particular night with wings in the
gameplay trailer is another one of the
major demigods
according to miyazaki part of the design
of these major characters
is that inheriting the shards of the
elder ring they each inherited
a different power or element so to speak
and each was twisted and warped in its
own way
and it brought a tainted strength to
each of them this
well describes why one of the demigods
has so many arms and i think that
could describe the wolf-like boss we see
in the gameplay trailer as well
who just might be another one of the six
demigods
one thing i still wonder about is the
blacksmith in the trailer
do you think it could be this character
from the gameplay trailer with
dreadlocks
i'm honestly not sure some more story
related details we know about elder ring
are that
for the most part the story will be told
more akin to the souls games or
bloodborne
with fragments the player will need to
piece together i'm personally a fan of
this style of storytelling and games
which is why i've made several from
software lore videos over the years
and i'm looking forward to discovering
an all new mythology this way
although for those of you who like the
story to be a little less obtuse
it does sound like the game's surface
level story will be a little easier to
understand
and possibly take some cues from the
storytelling of sekito
as with every modern from software game
there will be multiple endings to elden
ring this one deserves its own category
i'm sure we all fondly remember the
valley of defilement
blighttown harvest valley the nightmare
frontier
farron keep and the ocean and deaths
maybe even the big mine
the path of poison or mines filled with
bacon logs over poison
for my king's full bros out there ah yes
the best areas of any from software game
poison swamps the best
the best they're back we have
confirmation elder ring will have a
poison swamp
oh boy
[Music]
eldon ring releases january 21 2022.
let me know if there any details that
have you excited and what i might have
missed between this and my trailer
breakdown
if you enjoyed this video please
consider giving it a like and make sure
to stick to gamespot for more elton ring
i guarantee you that myself and to more
hussein will be incessantly talking
about elder ring the closer and closer
to release we get
and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
foreign